the arrival of the BMW 1500 in 1961
marked the start of a new era for the
Bavarian car maker classic car experts
gustav bauer takes us on a trip back in
time he says that BMW was in crisis in
the early 1950s and was even in danger
of being taken over by archrival
Mercedes that's because apart from
motorbikes BMW produced just two kinds
of vehicles small cars and luxury sedans
or as de Spiegel magazine put it cars
for laborers and CEOs so the 1500 was
aimed at the middle classes it was the
first of what became known as BMWs new
class to make the new class palatable to
the middle classes BMW used just the
right ingredients to make it practical
the 1500 had four doors its
four-cylinder engine was thrifty but
still delivered 80 horsepower and at a
price of 8500 dorch marks it made many a
family man's mouth water christophe says
the BMW 1500 made its debut at the
Frankfurt Motor Show in 1961 it thrilled
the crowds and around 2,000 orders were
taken than in there but BMW took its
time putting the model into series
production when the association of the
automotive industry threatened to
penalize BMW it took 35 pre-production
models put them on the assembly line for
another model and got some mechanics to
look like they were tinkering around
with the car then they said look mr.
inspector we're building it and it
worked which was a good thing as with
the new class BMW was one of the first
European car makers to venture into new
automotive terrain the modern
four-cylinder engine used in the 1500
would be fitted into other BMW models
for the next 25 years
the 1500 came to define what BMW stood
for as a brand for now listen Victor
Kristoph says the car looks small and
refined from the outside but inside it's
quite spacious which was by no means a
given for a car of its class in the
1960s but Christoph says it's a matter
of geometry experts know that a cube
boasts more volume than a sphere with
the same surface area and BMWs head
designer Vilhelm Hofmeister used this to
his advantage he defined the basic
features of BMWs design language
including the famous Hofmeister kink the
firm still uses today the characteristic
kidney radiator grille was the only
homage to BMWs glorious past otherwise
the 1500 broke with tradition completely
the cars delicate and almost rectangular
roof lets in plenty of light the sharp
angles and side seams were a novelty at
the time but continue to add Verve to
automotive design to this day the foam
upholstery in the middle of the steering
wheel was an early concession to passive
safety just like the sunken instruments
which don't reflect in the windshield
the new class offered drivers and
passengers lots of room in a relatively
small space and kristef says the 1500's
four-cylinder powerplant is the stuff of
legend it has a cast-iron engine block
with an aluminum cylinder head and
overhead camshaft and a forged
crankshaft it's engineering wrote
automotive history in the 1980s some BMW
design engineers took a couple of these
engines with a service life of over
100,000 kilometers fitted them with a
turbocharger and sent them onto the
Formula One circuits of this world with
as much as 1,300 horsepower under the
hood it sounds absurd but it was enough
to win the 1983 Formula One World
Championships
this modest-looking engine ranks among
the most legendary in the history of
motorsport never in his wildest dreams
could developer Alexander from Falcon
housen have imagined that his innovation
would end up writing Formula One history
with the help of the m10 engine Nelson
Piquet took the 1983 driver's
championship his Brabham BMW is still
considered to be one of the most
powerful ever seen in Formula One
the four-speed transmission shifts
crisply and the suspension is well tuned
in the early 60s the BMW 1500 even gave
Porsches a run for their money
christos says it might not sound like
much today but at the time eking 80
horsepower out of 4 cylinders was like
declaring war on the competition
Porsches base model 356 had just 60
horsepower the 1500 was called a
sprinter in a tux and Christoph thinks
Mattson apt description he says this 1.5
liter engine is very responsive but at
4,500 rpms it's pretty loud and sounds a
little labored but BMW already had
improvements in the works later new
class models like the BMW 2002tii with
up to two liters of cubic capacity and
130 horsepower helped drivers such as
hoover tannerite touring car history BMW
produced the model range for a decade
selling over 360,000 vehicles
Christophe says there's no question that
as the first midsize BMW of the post-war
era the new class route automotive
history and almost single-handedly saved
the company from bankruptcy even today
folks at BMW are proud of this car's
most important feature how fun it is to
drive so Christoph says the BMW 1500 is
definitely a milestone in automotive
history you could say that the BMW 1500
fill the gap left by the borg vard
isabella it's modern design was inspired
by the American Chevrolet Corvair and
numerous Italian models but in its day
the BMW 1500 was pretty much in a class
all its own
you